make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we return to our what-if series
where we ask and answer the question
what if Jason Todd became a spirit of
vengeance so before we get started we
need to lay some groundwork first in
terms of when this story would take
place as most of you may know Jason Todd
was created by Jerry Conway and Dom
Newton to be a replacement for Dick
Grayson who had outgrown the role of
Batman's sidekick and was functioning as
a leader of the Teen Titans and becoming
more independent from Batman DC however
still wanted Batman to have a sidekick
because they thought the Robin character
gave younger readers someone that could
identify with and also because of money
and so Jason Todd was introduced to
become the new Robin now what happened
however was it fans largely hated the
character mostly because in their minds
Dick Grayson was and always would be
Robin so in 1988 DC decided to try
something to connect with their fans and
offered them the chance to actually
decide what would happen in the Batman
comics by voting via a hotline that was
set up
and so after Jason is brutally beaten by
the Joker with a crowbar in Batman
number 427 phase were given the chance
to cast their votes as to whether he
should live or die now over 10,000 votes
were cast largely by a guy who was
cheating and by a margin of only 72
votes
DC's readers decided that Jason Todd
should die and so that's exactly what
happened Jason Todd was never seen or
heard from again until 2005 when writer
Judd Winick introduced a new villain
into the Batman mythos known as Red Hood
which turned out to be Jason Todd who
would come to Gotham to get revenge on
Batman for not avenging his death
against the Joker and because he's angry
that Tim Drake had replaced him as Robin
now it was later revealed that because
of the reality warping punches of
superboy-prime during Infinite Crisis
Jason Todd had returned a life and was
subsequently taken in by Talia al Ghul
and she put him in the Lazarus Pit to
restore his health and his memories but
we're going to ignore all that which
really begs the question why we cover in
the first place and pick up the story
shortly after Jason Todd dies now in our
story Mephisto who's one of several
versions of the devil in Marvel Comics
has found a way to the DC Universe
through some portal in the underworld
and when Jason dies Mephisto claims his
soul and brings him to the underworld
and holds him there for a number of
years now while Jason's soul is
imprisoned things unfold in the DC
Universe
just as they had before and so Batman
moves on is not avenge Jason's death and
takes on Tim Drake as his replacement
Robin and for his years of confinement
but Fisto allows jason to see the
happening as a form of torture now
eventually the Fisto comes to Jason with
an offer he'll release him from his
confinement but to do so he must take on
the spirit of vengeance and become a
Ghost Rider now what does Mephisto get
out of this he gets to see chaos and
destruction come to the DC Universe at
his hand and this makes him happy
because you know he's like you guys and
me we love to see comic book universes
get destroyed by people so obviously
Jason agrees to become the Ghost Rider
after all vengeance is what he's wanted
ever since his death vengeance against
the one who killed him the one who
allowed it to happen and the one who
tried to take his place and so Jason
decides to surveil the Joker and wait
until he put some nefarious plan into
place knowing that in doing so Batman
and Robin would likely arrive on the
scene and he can take out all three
objects of his wrath at once now
everything seems to go according to plan
right the Joker begins his shenanigans
Batman and Robin show up to stop him but
then all three find themselves encircled
in a ring of fire now on the outside of
the circle we see the charred remains of
all of Joker's henchmen and Batman and
Robin and the Joker are all surprised to
see a man with a flaming skull walk
through the flames now one thing I also
want to specify here Jason Todd should
be wearing his red hood when this
happens it would look awesome right like
a flaming red hood would be Beast you
don't okay here's the thing
somebody draw that somebody somebody
send me fan art of that send it to me on
Twitter right twitter.com slash comics
explain somebody send me fan art of that
my favorite instance of that fan art
will have their tweet pinned and I'll
send you a robb core range so somebody
send me some fan art I think that would
be awesome now while this is all going
on The Joker starts laughing like a
crazy person because that's what he is
but Batman is in shock at the sight of
his former Protege Jason he asked once
he finally gathers his wits and then Tim
Drake responds wait Jason as in Jason
Todd I thought you said he died oh I did
and I went to hell for years all because
of these two and I watched the world
move on without me wanting nothing more
than to get revenge for what happened to
me and my time is finally here now
Joker's laughing intensifies and Jason's
flaming skull returns and he punches a
stream of hellfire at the Joker without
any warning
incinerating him on the spot now Jason
then turns his attention to Tim and
Batman tries to convince him that he
doesn't need to do this that Tim had
nothing to do with what happened to him
but Jason is undeterred and begin
dancing towards them now Batman tells
Tim to give the Batmobile and go back to
the Batcave which is kind of stupid
because it's not like Jason Todd doesn't
know where it is but Tim Drake refuses
saying that he won't leave Batman there
alone and so Batman hits a button on his
suit and the Batmobiles autopilot
engages and it pulls up beside them and
the door opens Batman pushes him into
the car and it speeds away after that he
speaks into a communicator on his wrist
Tim when you get back
call the Justice League now Batman
readies for battle against his former
sidekick fighting admirably but he's no
match for the immense power of the Ghost
Rider and so Batman is beaten soundly
most likely because he didn't have time
to prep and Jason speaks to him once
more imagine if you will having to
relive and feel the pain of everything
you've ever done that you regret I can
make that happen I didn't try it with
the Joker because he's too nuts to even
understand the concept of penance but
you are not you failed me by not killing
the Joker before he killed me you had a
million chances but you never had the
guts to do it then you failed me again
by refusing to avenge my death and now
you failed your new Robin because you
haven't saved him I won't rest until he
joins you in hell and then Batman
responds Tim hasn't done anything wrong
and then Jason Todd responds neither had
I but I was still dragged down to the
underworld and forced to watch him live
the life that should have been mine his
blood is on your hands Bruce that you're
to blame for what will happen to him and
so Batman begins to speak again but
before he can jason performs the penance
stare on it which causes him to
experience all the pain he had inflicted
on others in his lifetime and so all the
guilt of Batman feels for what happened
to his parents what happened to Jason
and what he believes will happen to Tim
as a result of his actions all twists
his soul to a point that is too much to
bear and he cries out in agony before
he's eventually killed at the hands of
the Ghost Rider now back at the Batcave
Tim does his Batman told him and calls
the Justice League he tells them who the
ghost rider is and they agree to come to
Wayne Manor is they believe that the
ghost rider will come looking for Tim
now Superman Wonder Woman the flash and
Green Lantern make it to the manor
simultaneously as ghost riders arrival
they tell him to stand down
but of course he doesn't and a battle
ensues surprisingly anything that
Justice League dishes out ghost rider
seems to be able to take without
sustaining any damage and if this seems
far-fetched it should be pointed out
just how powerful the ghost rider is
sidetrack ghost riders are powered by
extremely potent demonic energy and in
addition to being able to perform the
penance stare and manipulate Hellfire
they also have superhuman physical
attributes and are effectively
invulnerable and immortal and so after
the Justice League realizes what it is
they're dealing with here they decide to
fall back and formulate a plan and so
they take Robin and Alfred with them to
their headquarters to prevent the ghost
rider from harming them and they begin
to formulate set plan now it doesn't
take them long to realize that they're
dealing with some sort of mystical
element as Ghost Rider was able to deal
significant damage to Superman who has
an inherent weakness to magic and so
they call in all their allies who deal
in the mystic realm and so we get cetana
dr. fate and John Constantine basically
we could get the monkey guy the
detective monkey guy detective chimp but
he doesn't really count but when they
described what they saw none of them
have any idea where this guy with a
flaming skull came from is etana and dr.
fate agreed to help the Justice League
take down the Ghost Rider any way they
can
Constantine however says that he's not
much good in a fight wishes them luck
and then leaves meanwhile we see that
jason is continuing to plague the DC
Universe as the Ghost Rider he's burned
down Wayne Manor taken over the Batcave
as his headquarters and is using the
Batmobile as his ride instead of a
motorcycle as the ghost riders of the
Marvel Universe typically do Jason
continues to operate as the Ghost Rider
basically doing the bidding of Mephisto
and waiting for the day that he'll have
a face-to-face with the Justice League
again now when that day comes the league
and their magical allies appear and once
again engage in battle with similar
results even though skilled and the
mystic arts seem unable to faze the
ghost rider as their magic seems to have
no effect on him now as the battle goes
on Ghost Rider begins to gain the upper
hand as as Hellfire attacks
prove to be devastating against the leak
the battle is soon joined however by a
very unlikely ally John Constantine now
Ghost Rider turns his attention to
Constantine and attempts a penance stare
but to his surprise it has no effect on
it and what we find out here is it
similar to when the Punisher had the
penance stare performed on him by Johnny
Blaze the penance stare does not work on
Constantine because he has no regret for
anything he's done Constantine tells The
Ghost Rider
that if he knows what's good for him
he'll go back to where he came from now
at this point Jason is incredulous I
fought your greatest heroes and come
through without a scratch what are the
likes of you going to do and then
Constantine comes along with his British
accent I've already done my part I've
brought
here and and that's a terrible British
accent and Jason looks around and stares
an oo at what he sees the spectre and so
what we have here is a showdown of the
demonic spirit of vengeance with the
living embodiment of God's vengeance in
the DC Universe and I really think that
it would take an entity like the spectre
to defeat the Ghost Rider as they are
essentially two sides of the same coin
but with the spectre doing the bidding
of the presence the most powerful entity
in the DC Universe he would be able to
eventually defeat Ghost Rider and so
after an epic battle with the spectre
emerging as the victor the spirit of
vengeance is separated from Jason Todd
and it along with Mephisto is thrown
into the Phantom Zone in an attempt to
keep it forever imprisoned since it
cannot be destroyed and this would allow
for the threat to remain in the DC
Universe with the possibility of it
getting out at some point in the future
because that's what always seems to
happen whenever something goes into the
Phantom Zone they always end up escaping
but for now the threat of the Ghost
Rider is neutralized but the destruction
he caused would actually change the DC
landscape forever Jason Todd would
likely be placed in Arkham Asylum as his
time as a Ghost Rider and the subsequent
separation from the spirit of vengeance
would likely drive him crazy with Batman
gone we would likely see Dick Grayson
adopting the mantle of Batman in
continuing with Tim Drake as his Robin
until Bruce was inevitably resurrected
by DC riders at some point in the future
because he's too popular to kill off
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob pork do you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
that we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you